- I asked on Twitter,
a little Twitter poll,
have any of you actually
lied to the pollsters,
about your support for Trump?
Hundreds of people said yes.
And they weren't
saying we might lie,
or we think we'll
do it in the future,
they said we have, this year.
(upbeat music)
- It's Locals week, here
on the Rubin Report,
and I'm doing a series
of mini interviews
with creators, on why
they decided to become
less reliant on big tech,
and instead own their
content, community,
and livelihood with Locals.com.
Joining me today, is the
creator of the legendary
"Dilbert" comic strip,
as well as a best selling author
and guy who really,
really loves coffee,
Scott Adams.
Welcome back to
the Rubin Report.
- Thanks, Dave.
Thanks for having me.
- How much coffee
do you drink a day?
I always think you're just
drinking coffee
constantly, basically.
- Christina, my wife
gave me a new trick,
where I only do half coffee,
and half hot water,
and instead of coffee, it's
like a coffee flavored beverage
that you can drink more of it.
So, that's my curtain trick
for doubling my output.
- I think that's a little
bit like an Americano, right?
Isn't that when you go to Europe
and you drink an Americano?
It's just coffee and they
just add water to it,
I think, maybe.
- I don't know my coffees,
but I'm gonna say yes.
I'm just gonna say yes to that.
- You got very Long Island
there when you said coffee.
Your coffee, you don't
know your coffee.
- Well, I'm Upstate New York,
so we drink coffee and
we go off on the roof,
and down by the creek.
- All right.
- We go swimming in the creek.
- Well, I'm gonna send you one
of these Locals coffee mugs,
we've got one.
But before we get into Locals,
and you've absolutely
just crushed it on there,
um, I wanted to talk about
something separate all together.
Which is that because we
live in this strange time,
where it seems no one can
make sense of anything,
you're one of the people
on a very short list,
that can probably
do it on one hand.
People who I think are
actually making some sense.
Did you ever think you were
gonna be a sense-maker?
I mean, that's partly what
being a comic guy is.
You're making little quips,
and you're trying to
make sense of the world.
But did you ever think it was
gonna be this level of it?
- You're asking me the
most embarrassing questions
you possibly could,
because the answer is yes.
- Ah, you're supposed
to be humble here.
- Yeah, I know.
The answer's yes
and my whole life, actually.
So, I always had an image
that some day,
I didn't know what
path I would take,
but that I would be doing
something in public,
in which I would be
explaining things to people
who needed a little help
having things explained.
So, it's amazing that it
ended up the way it ended up.
Cause the way I got here
could not have been predicted
in any way.
But yes, the answer is
I did see my future
exactly like this.
- Yeah, are you shocked though,
to see that the general
systems of sense-making,
our institutions, the media,
the rest of the stuff that
guys like us spend most
of our day talking about?
Are you shocked to see how
rapidly they've crumbled,
or is this,
is this just the
last gasp of air?
Like, what's
happening right now?
- Well, I think Trump uh,
took the last bit of
credibility outta the system.
But, all he did was reveal
what the system was.
I don't think that
he changed it,
as much as he revealed it,
and then we could see it.
So, who knows how corrupt
the news used to be.
I used to hear stories
back in Kennedy's day
of the Kennedy would
go out in the yacht
and the take uh,
take the New York Times,
or the other top
reporters with him.
And did he get good coverage?
Of course he did.
(chuckling)
So, things are different,
but I dunno if
they're more corrupt.
I think we just might be
a little more aware of it.
And the thing that Trump did,
is he just completely just said,
I think I'll just say
whatever I wanna say,
as long as it leads
me in a productive way
that's good for the country.
Didn't worry about the facts,
and it didn't hurt him at all.
He became president doing that,
when everybody was saying,
well, you can't be president,
if you keep saying things
that the fact-checkers
don't agree with.
And then he did.
And he proved that it
didn't matter that much.
- So, didn't worry
about the facts.
When people criticize you,
or they criticize me,
or some of the other people
that are just walking around.
Not even that are necessarily
rah-rah Trump people,
but just don't suffer from
Trump derangement syndrome.
That's the thing,
the facts, the facts,
the facts, the facts.
How do you, I've heard you
explain it a little bit,
but how do you explain his,
sort of loose relationship
with the facts?
- Well, I call it uh,
directionally accurate.
So, if Trump says
something like,
well, there were 40,000
people at my rally,
but the real number was 25,000,
that's kinda the same, right?
It doesn't change how
you think about it.
A lot of people
came to the rally.
How much should it have been?
Well, I dunno.
If he says the economy is the
best economy we've ever had,
but it's only the best
one in the last 40 years,
does that help us or
does that hurt us?
Well, it helps us,
because the economy is
a psychology engine,
as I like to say.
If you think it's doing well,
you invest, you buy,
you have confidence.
And then it does well.
So, he has the ability
to use hyperbole,
and a little bit
of exaggeration,
to make things work
better than they would've
worked without it.
Which is completely different
than a flat out lie,
like let's say that
the fine people hoax,
that's nothing but
a divisive lie.
That's a bad,
missing the fact checking.
That's as bad as you can get.
But, if you're just
talking something up
that needs to be
talked up, that's fine.
- Yeah, I actually wasn't
gonna bring this up,
but let's just do it real quick,
before we get to your community.
The very fine people hoax.
You were one of
the first people,
at least, sort of like
mainstream-ish people,
or someone with come
cred, let's say,
that was calling out the
very fine people hoax,
and pointing out
that before he said
very fine people on both sides,
which he meant about
the monument argument
in and of itself, that really,
he had condemned the white
nationalists and the KKK
the sentence before.
Biden has said that
this is the reason
that he is running
for president,
yet the media doesn't
call him out on it.
- I dunno.
- Does anything shock
you at this point?
- I really don't understand
if the media doesn't
know it's a lie,
because they've been reporting
it as true for so long,
and they all believe
that they saw it.
They saw it with their own eyes,
heard it with their own ears.
And what they saw and
heard was the edited part.
- [Dave] Right.
- Where they take out the
sentence where he clarified
that he totally wasn't
talking about those people.
- [Dave] Yeah.
- In the clear, clear
as possible words.
They just leave that out.
And that is misleading.
So uh, the fact that
the media does that
is still puzzling to me,
'cause I can't tell
how intentional it is,
or if they're really just
fooled by their own propaganda.
- Right.
- It's hard to tell.
- It's kinda, I
always think it's like
they've gone so deep with it
and repeated it so many times,
that it would be just too,
it would like
shatter their world,
basically, if they had to
admit that it wasn't true,
with something like that.
- Yeah, that's why uh,
Trump basically could
win the election
just by bringing
that up at a debate.
And just stop the show,
bring that up and say, look,
here's the deal, people,
go look up the transcript,
see for yourself if
they've been lying about
the central theme
of the campaign.
I won't even tell
ya what I think.
Just go look at the transcript.
Get back at me.
That'd be the end of,
that'd be the end of it.
- Can you imagine
that during a debate,
if he just literally said,
I'm actually not even gonna,
I have two minutes,
I'm not gonna talk for the
next minute and a half.
Google it right now.
That would actually,
it would crack the internet.
- Google fine people hoax,
those three words,
and you'll get all you want.
- There you go.
All right, Scott.
Let's talk about your
Locals community.
Because you were one
of the first people,
that we brought onboard.
You were on Patreon before,
and I kinda was like,
I think we got a
better option for ya.
We took a couple meetings.
You jumped onboard.
Could you just tell
me a little bit
about what your
experience has been like,
and why you think
what you're doing
over there is working?
Cause it really is working.
You've got a very
vibrant community.
- Yeah, it's far
exceeded my expectations.
It's way better than I thought.
And the problem I was having
with the other social media,
from YouTube and Twitter,
is that I couldn't
control what anybody saw.
Cause Twitter could
shadow ban me.
YouTube could de-monetize me.
And it looked like
one wrong move,
and I would just
be outta business.
So, here I am putting tons
of work into something,
that I have no control over.
They can just snap a finger
and I'm outta business.
So, I thought wouldn't
it be good to have
one place where there's
only subscribers,
they wanna be there.
There are basically no trolls.
Because trolls don't wanna
subscribe to something
to just complain.
So, it ends up being
this happy place,
where you don't get
all the nastiness
of the other platforms,
and I can't be canceled.
It's sorta perfect.
And monetarily it's been,
like I said,
it exceeded my expectations,
almost embarrassingly.
- Yeah, do you think that
the future of the internet
is subscription based,
as opposed to ad based,
or in effect that we,
the free people are the product?
- Well, if I speak for myself,
I can't handle ads anymore.
Not any kind of ads.
I can't watch regular TV.
I just can't watch
anything with an ad.
So, even on YouTube I'll
pay the subscription,
so I don't have
to watch the ads.
So, I can't see other
people being that different.
I think social media has,
has shortened our
collective attention spans.
So, sitting there for
like five minutes of ads,
or even one minute,
of advertising seems,
it just seems impossible now.
Where in the old
days you thought,
well, it's just a minute.
- [Dave] Right.
- And now a minute
seems like a long time.
- I mean, a minute, man,
when I'm watching YouTube
and there's a seven
second unskippable ad,
it's like, I'm
pressing that uh Roku.
I'm pressing that button,
over, and over,
and over, and over.
Trying to buy back
a second of my life.
- Yeah, I'm trying
to start a hobby.
I'm like, seven seconds,
what can I?
(laughing)
- What can I do
with seven seconds?
So, one of the things
that I think is,
is interesting about what
you've done with your community,
is you're putting
edgier content there.
Stuff that either you
kinda wanna test out
with your own people,
or you think maybe is
gonna bring you more flack
from the normies.
Um, what was the
idea behind that?
- Yeah, there's some
types of content,
that if you put it out
in the general public,
it just attracts trolls.
But if I'm in my
subscription community,
it's only people who
want to be there.
So, people, they may comment
that they disagree with it,
but it'll be a
polite disagreement.
So, there's lots of stuff
that I just wouldn't bother
putting on the regular internet,
because I just don't wanna
deal with the blow back.
But on Locals, as I
often say to them,
I go, don't spread
this outside of Locals.
Not like they could if
they wanted to, but.
But I ask them to,
and they don't.
Weirdly.
That's amazing too.
Imagine thousands of people,
and I say this would
really get me in trouble,
don't put this on the internet,
and they don't.
They don't.
(chuckling)
Now, none of it would kill me.
So, I'm not gonna
put anything there
that's gonna take
me down completely.
But I really appreciate
the fact that they,
they actually keep it on Locals.
- Yeah, can you
talk a little bit,
just about the
community side of it,
and what kinda interactions
you're having with people there,
'cause like everybody else
that I'm talking to this week,
and myself included.
It's like we can get into it
with the trolls
and all the haters,
and all of that stuff.
But you said,
they're not even there.
So, you're getting some
actual human communication.
- Yeah, the part of what I
didn't expect is that the uh,
the other community
people who just
are paying money to follow me,
I didn't understand
how much content they would
be posting themselves.
And at first, when I saw
other people posting,
to be honest, my
first impression was,
hey, I'm the one who
should be posting.
Hey.
- [Dave] Right, right.
- How 'bout a little
more about me, huh, huh?
And then I started
looking at their posts,
and I was like well,
that's pretty good.
And then see another one,
it's like huh, I didn't
see that on Twitter.
That's very interesting.
So, they end up curating
all these things that
since they know I'm
the sorta leader
of the community,
they assume other
people in the community
would like what I would like.
And they end up
guessing really well,
what I would be interested in.
So, it's fascinating that way.
Then there are a lot
of direct messages,
people pay a little bit
more to direct message me,
and I try to answer
all of those if I can.
- Yeah.
How different do you think
the Internet's gonna look
in five or 10 years?
Do you think we're really like,
like, I'm starting to
feel like we're really
at the end of this
version of the internet.
That in a certain way,
this election almost feels
like the end of everything.
The debates feel like
the end of the debates.
I feel like we've taken
Facebook and Twitter,
we've taken all of these
things to their end conclusion.
And that the internet
of 2024, 2025
is gonna be way, way different
than what we're
looking at right now.
- Well, I've argued that
artificial intelligence
has already taken
over the world.
Um, it's just not exactly the
way we thought it would be.
It's not in a robot body,
it doesn't talk to us.
But the algorithms of the
social media platforms,
they decide what you see.
And they decide based
on a simple rule,
of what's gonna
make the most money,
and nobody goes to jail.
Just a few other considerations.
And as long as that algorithm
is going toward
that one outcome,
it's gonna cause people to
be at each other's necks.
So a lot of the,
the fighting and the conflict,
and the divisiveness,
comes from math,
it comes from the algorithms.
It's not people deciding
that we should fight,
it's the machine.
The machine decided
that we're gonna fight.
And the machine decided
that I'm gonna see something
that's gonna make my
hair catch on fire.
And then I go over to Locals,
there's no algorithm.
There's just people
doing what they wanna do,
with the people they
wanna do it with.
And suddenly I feel
like it's human,
it's human contact again.
It's like real people.
But, I think AI is literally,
I don't mean this
in a figurative,
analogy kind of way.
I think it's behind us,
the takeover.
I don't think it's
in front of us.
- The game is fixed and
we keep playing anyway.
All right, Scott,
gimme a prediction
for the election.
Have you made an
official prediction yet?
- Well, I been saying that
Trump would win from the start.
He's sucking air in the polls,
but I'm gonna stick
with my prediction
that the polls are inaccurate,
and people are lying
to those pollsters,
because it's funny.
(chuckling)
It's funny.
I asked on Twitter,
a little Twitter poll,
uh, have any of you actually
lied to the pollsters
about your support for Trump?
Hundreds of people said yes.
And they weren't
saying we might lie,
or we think we'll
do it in the future,
they said we have, this year.
(chuckling)
- Yeah, well what.
- So.
- I saw, I saw today
as we're taping this,
we're holding it for a few days,
but I saw an article
that was from four
years ago today,
and it said, it had the
average of the polls
were Hillary up by 14 points,
and Hillary obviously lost.
So, right now when they show ya,
okay, Biden's up
by maybe 4 points,
it's like, guys, deja
vu all over again,
I mean come on.
- It could be,
but the one thing that you
can count on with 2020,
is we're not done.
We're not done.
It's not like we're gonna wait
and nothing's gonna happen
between now and election day.
There's a lot that's
gonna happen between then.
And so, anything could happen.
- Ain't it the truth?
All right.
Like a professional,
pimp out your Local,
so we can send people over there
and they can see all that
tolerance and decency.
- Yes, it's
ScottAdams.Locals.com.
Did I get that right?
- You did.
That's what I have right here.
Very impressive, Scott Adams.
You are a man of persuasion.
- Thanks for having me.
- All right.
Thanks my friend.
If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful conversations
about politics,
instead of non-stop yelling,
check out our politics playlist,
and if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode playlist,
all right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.